a newly released video recorded by the
u.s navy personnel two years ago
shows an unknown sphere that followed a
navy warship before
disappearing into the ocean the video
provides the latest glimpse into an
ongoing pentagon investigation
into ufos i-team reporter george knapp
unveils details about the encounter
earlier on today on our mystery wire
website george
ryan you know uh ufos are in the air if
i'm here in the studio something's going
on
now this video was made public today by
our colleague filmmaker jeremy corbell
with analysis and background on mystery
wire
the unknown object was one of several
that essentially surrounded the navy
warship
multiple times over three days four
other navy ships had similar encounters
over a period of several days in july
2019
at least five u.s navy warships based in
san diego
were swarmed by drone-like objects of
unknown origin
one of those ships the uss omaha was on
maneuvers more than 100 miles directly
west of san diego
and beyond the channel islands one of
the omaha's central missions is
surveillance so it's packed
with cutting edge technology and sensors
but it appears the omaha was itself
under surveillance
this video was recorded inside the
omaha's command center
just before 11 pm on july 15. the image
on the screen shows a six foot in
diameter sphere that
traveled alongside the omaha for about
an hour
it was pitch black outside so the image
was obtained via a thermal sensor
personnel in the command center made
multiple recordings of what was on the
screen
at precisely 11 p.m the unidentified
spear
seemingly vanished into the ocean
splashed when they say splash splash
that doesn't mean there was a physical
splash
that means this object went into the
water or they suspect
it did filmmaker jeremy corbell obtained
the video from sources he declines to
identify
in april corbell and mystery wire
released a series of other
startling images that are included in a
briefing presentation
prepared by the uap task force a unit
created by congress last year
to collect ufo-related images and
information
for a comprehensive report due next
month one
image from the uap task force is a
freeze frame slide
of the sphere seen beside the omaha the
pentagon has confirmed that image was
captured by navy personnel
the task force considers it to be a
genuine unknown
other journalists have confirmed that
multiple navy ships in the same vicinity
were buzzed by unknown objects during
the same time
frame july 2019 corbell says as many as
14 of the spheres
surrounded the omaha and were detected
on sensors
on and off during three perplexing days
at sea
the omaha's advanced sensors could not
maintain a lock on the spheres
as they approached the ship or when they
departed they never found
where these things came from or went to
so they don't know where they're
launching from or going from i mean
maybe it's the water because that's what
we're seeing one do
mark bearing voices on the video
confirmed the omaha launched an
immediate search using all of its
high-tech resources but when the
spear vanished from the screen it also
vanished from the omaha's radar and
sonar
no wreckage was found on the surface
the uap task force briefing is a
classified document but the images
contained in that briefing
are not classified that distinction was
made so the task force could use images
like this to brief other military and
intelligence officials
about the ufo mystery simply put the
navy does not know what these things are
they are still considered to be unknown